c'est en rockstar tel un freddy mercury
que jean leloup est apparu sur la scène
du métropolis pour le premier d'une
série de spectacles en salle trois ans
après sa tournée de festivals
voilà
quelques-unes de ces bombes ont servi de
mise en bouche avant d'entamer des
nouveautés dont petit papillon dames
holtz et papillon qui trouve le toner
eh oui
à
avec l'ajout d'un quintette à cordes
l'interprétation des chansons tirées de
son vaste répertoire est maintenant plus
grandiose sans pour autant être pompeuse
jean leloup reste fidèle à lui même avec
sa fougue électrisante aucun temps mort
sur scène il est en pleine possession de
ses moyens devant une foule captive qui
comprend ses fans de la première heure
autant que de nouveaux adeptes est
possible de résister aux charmes du
merveilleux monde de le loup dans un
décor ludique bonifié d'éclairage
parfois psychédéliques le soleil qui
domine la scène en première partie est
remplacée par une lune dans la deuxième
faisant vraisemblablement écoute titre
du spectacle splendeur et chute de
paradis city
non
apparu
ap
chez dr jean leloup a été peu bavard
pendant les trois heures de spectacle
mais très généreuse de son énergie et en
cette soirée de première il à en faire
non pas un mais deux rappels en
survolant la foule sur sa passerelle
comme jean leloup ne fait rien comme les
autres son retour sur scène se fera en
deux temps en plus de la version
orchestrale
il présentera un spectacle solo à
montréal ottawa et québec ici tanya
lapointe radio canada montréal